okay queen i am
you are you are incredible
you were incredible in this film but
anytime i know your name is gonna be a
part of something anytime i see your
name on it
i already know what i'm getting i am
getting greatness
i know you picked the role very
specifically and i know you're going to
put your heart and soul into it
this was no exception viola truly
um how does it feel so early in the gate
to
get oscar buzz already i know you've
been nominated i know you've won
but for something as special as this um
it feels good i mean listen the oscar
buzz is going to be whatever it is but
really what you what you wanted was to
put
what i want is to fulfill the role
that's what i want
because me denzel we're all this
we're the same once we do a roll and
it's done it's done you know of course
with oscar with just
you know and and promoting the movie and
doing the oscar season you have to keep
talking and talking about it
yeah but really i mean i just
i loved playing her i love playing
with all of those actors yeah that was
my oscar
that was my oscar whatever else i get
will just be the cherry on top
i've worked with him many times and he's
incredible
so it's a difficult question to ask you
but for chadwick to be
honored and celebrated in this film
what does it mean for you
it means that they are
absolutely going in the right direction
because he's a
wonderful artist yeah he's a great
artist
that was met with a great role he
fulfilled it
yeah and if you are if you were ever in
the presence of chadwick boseman you
would just know
his integrity came into the room before
he did
yeah he absolutely was not interested in
ego any
nothing and everything every person in
his life was intentional
every person that he accepted in his
life was intentional
every role he chose was intentional
and um i just feel like he's going to be
greatly missed
because of not just that but i'm sure if
you talk to his family
it's his heart man yeah he's
just his heart you know he just you know
in a world
of so many people who are out for
themselves and who
living someone else's dreams and who you
don't know who they are
from one day to the next here was
someone who busted out of all of that
and yeah so
yeah i know it's a tough one um
you know you and chadwick are being
honored at this year's gotham awards
um what will that be like for you
this year great i'm i'm happy to be in
this company
my i was telling someone that uh every
single time
we would go to events and we saw him
because that's when you see actors
he would never leave me and my husband's
side hmm
it was it really was i i actually was
blown away by that and i'm telling you
hundreds of people
coming up to him surrounding him yeah
telling him to come to a different area
he didn't want to move
from our side there's a part of me
my my fantasy
not to make his mom mad but that made me
it made me feel like
we were maternal and paternal
um and he would talk to my husband
for hours and my husband would talk to
him and then he would just
just latch onto him and
that's what i missed the most because i
i know he meant a lot to us
too i want to say we loved you too you
know chadwick
but he loved us yeah love this
yeah and i know you i know you did that
maternal role before so i know you
you guys i loved that i remembered that
it was so fun
you